still in shock children from the village
of karma in Northern Burkina Faso
gathered to explain what actually
happened to them and how they survived
we were on the way to the well with my
donkey when we saw them moving towards
us we hid in our homes our father came
out they took our identification and
started firing at them killing them all
they then destroyed the homes and killed
our mothers I was hiding underneath
piles of bodies as they continued to
fire at us
the government say armed groups linked
to isil and Al-Qaeda dressed in army
uniforms attacked the villagers but the
survivors say that's not true
soldiers
but the Euphoria turned to a massage
some of the survivors say they used
airplanes during the attack some thing
armed groups do not have access to there
were a thousand men dressed in military
uniforms with Bearer arms removing
armored vehicles with a flag of Burkina
Faso marked on them
the government says 60 people were
killed but villagers say over 145 people
died 45 of them children during an
attack that lasted eight hours when the
villagers went to bury their dead
soldiers took phones and deleted photos
that could appear as evidence of their
involvement an investigation is underway
to find those responsible
to what these villagers describe as an
unjustified barbaric act by soldiers
meant to protect them
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera